all right Abby yes Abby uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally I
was born in Mexico but I was brought
here when I was two years old and I grew
up here in Los Angeles
um I went to school here and you know
from there I've been here all my life
yep tell me about your family growing up
I am uh I'm the oldest and we're seven
of us and um it's me and my sister and
then five little brothers so which
they're not so little anymore but yeah
and well I basically was their mom
throughout the whole you know throughout
my whole childhood I didn't have you
know the
a childhood because I had to take care
of my little brothers but my mom was a
single mother and you know she did what
she had to do and then I had to I had to
do what I had to do so
yeah it was very hard because I I missed
out on many things that my friends you
know got to do and I and I wasn't able
to do but
I have
um six amazing siblings so what was your
mom doing that she was a bartender yeah
at a bar and um you know she she managed
to take care of everything and it was I
mean it was seven of us you know but she
managed with my help but she managed to
how far are you in school I graduated
high school
um yeah but I graduated high school I
got pregnant when I was 17 but I still
managed to graduate yeah
how many kids do you have I have four
kids yeah I have four kids where are
they now
um they're currently with their father
and my aunties
um due to a fact that I I was married
and
I found out that my husband was having
some homosexual likes on Craigslist and
stuff I went crazy because he was an
amazing husband to me so that devastated
in my life so you know I went really
violent on him and I got a case for
domestic violence with him so that made
me you know have loose custody of my
kids
so now that's what that's why they're
there
yeah
and drugs are part of your life yes yeah
they became a part of my life well
actually I've been surrounded by drugs
all my life my mom you know but
um I was trying not to you know follow
the whole cycle of becoming like my
mother you know even though she was a
great mother but there was always drugs
involved but
um I try to break as much as I could but
when this event happened in my life I
just you know I couldn't and then at the
moment I was managing because I am a
certified bartender besides the other
things I do so I was managing four
restaurants and then um but this
happened so the
um starting to use drugs kind of like
helped me out because I was able to
manage and balance out like my kids my I
was fostering my little brother says
well so it was my kids fostering and
then my husband and then um the
restaurant so at the end it was too much
for me to balance so I lost my job I
lost my husband you know because we
divorced and then um and my brothers
were removed and my kids as well you
know but it was I think it was too much
and I was trying to manage everything at
once and it was very hard
you know
and and that's why you know now um now
drugs are part of my life and
I mean it's not like a good thing but I
I managed to like
say that I'm a functional user because
you know like I do I use it and I get a
lot of things done but at the end of the
day it's gonna affect me I I know that
what are you doing for money
I currently uh do
um fraud identity theft and I still
forklifts
yeah how do you steal forklifts well I I
drive around or I walk around and I spot
them and then I manage to you know use
bow Cutters to go in wherever they're at
and then the switch is very easy to
break
um I also well I have a partner that you
know we work together and he was the one
that put me on on the on the forklifting
and then we just see them and then we
wait for the perfect time and we just
you know drive off with them
yeah it's either we drive off with them
or like I follow him in the car or
something like that until we get it to
wherever it's gonna go
that's an interesting hustle it is very
interesting I I love the Toyotas they're
very um they you get cashed out very
much like five four to five bands so
everything cash
what is your drug
um
yeah you tried to quit I did try to quit
um I was I just have a two-year-old baby
that you know I did use drugs on her
pregnancy I tried to stop many times but
it was just you know I was it's just you
know I guess sometimes it's it's hard
you know so I did try and I stopped at
the end but at the you know just once I
was out of the pregnancy I just started
again
your friends yes well
a little bit of friends but it's mostly
guys though yeah I don't associate with
girls much because they tend to like
feel I don't know some type of way where
I'm around but it's you know I don't I
mean I don't get intimidated by them or
I don't even Envy them but they do so I
just managed to just stick with the boys
and then I had my little brother so I'm
already used to being around boys all
the time he
where are you staying now uh I
had a tent right now you're on the
street yeah yeah
I am you know I have a friend that's
well she's telling me to go to her house
but sometimes it's very hard to break
like you know certain um strings that
you have with the streets and sometimes
like I have like people that tell me
come and live with me and I do go but
and it's very comfortable and very like
nice but just the streets you know they
just call me
and yeah it's very addicting
you know to just be out here and you're
never getting you never get bored around
here you know especially in downtown
sometimes I think there's actually
something about the streets that is
drawing everyone yes even more than the
drugs Yes actually I know a lot of
people that have their own apartment but
they still manage they still in the
streets and it's crazy but I mean I
lived in myself now like I I have a
friend that lives in a nice apartment
complex but I'm there and then you have
everything you have a pool you have a
gym and I just want to be in the streets
is it the excitement the drama of all
that I think it's I don't I mean I don't
know I can tell you what it is but
I mean there's just like I don't know
maybe because when I was growing up I
wasn't able to like to go out and party
and all the parties were like if I had
parties it was in my house with my
little brothers in the room asleep and
then I will manage to our parties but I
wasn't able to go out or be in the
streets you know and now that once my
kids were removed I was devastated
because my brothers were removed as well
but I kind of feel like
fight I finally could get up and just
take care of myself you know I don't
have to change like like five diapers
and get all these kids together and and
then me you know so that also and then
you know now that I'm in the streets
it's kind of like it's kind of well it
was exciting but at the moment like as
days go by like I feel that my days are
just going darker without my kids you
know because I'm I am missing out a lot
I have a 14 year old daughter that I
already started dating and I'm very
afraid of that you know because I want
to be there because I know what it is
when you fall in love for the first time
you know and I want to be there to
protect her but I I just I can't
you know but I try to as much as I can I
talk to her all the time but you know
there's just certain things that as we
as we're growing up we think that that's
what we want but it's not like that you
know you you should learn you know with
time but
I'm just very afraid that I won't be
there like to support her or you know if
she needs me
is it the drug that is keeping you
out here or is it something else yeah
it's part it's part the drugs I believe
and then maybe like
maybe not having like the best support
team for me to get back on track you
know like my mother she's a great mom
but
you know she's doing her thing and um my
brother's like they're teenagers but
they're already like
they're already like operating like like
shop shops you know like wherever you
get arrested for things that
I'm like Mom like what are you doing
where are you know I mean and she tries
to be there as much as she can but it's
just something that we already have it
in us I guess and I don't know it's just
it's crazy but I told her like I was
speaking to her the other day and I said
like remember when we used to always say
like oh my God all these diapers but now
it's like I wish they could go back to
being babies because now it's really
like you know like my brother my little
brother just got shot like three months
ago in the head luckily it didn't really
do anything to him and it's like it's
very scary ones that are growing up you
know and
as much as I try like sometimes like
life is really hard right now and then
like the forklifting I'm telling you
like you I get cash to like four
thousand you know five thousand per
forklift so it's a lot of money yeah but
then that's money that just leaves like
this like it's easy money it's gonna
leave easy you know like you're it's
just it's not gonna be enough never I
believe because it's easy money
but I mean I'm I I went with that
decision because it's like if I'm gonna
risk my freedom and it best believe it
has to be for some good amount of money
you know I'm not gonna be doing like
little jobs because I'm I'm not like I'm
not gonna be wasting my time like that
you know it's just what does Christmas
do for you
huh what does crystal meth do for you uh
it usually uh gives me like the ability
and the energy to do multiple things and
get them done you know what I mean like
I I managed to like do it and then I
managed to like uh go out of here and do
that and go over here and like take care
of this you know I still call my kids
and still do this I still look amazing
like I do you know like so it kind of
like helps me out but but don't get me
wrong sometimes it it triggers you know
like sometimes I have bad days
where I'm like stuck or like
like I usually don't sleep like I sleep
maybe once a week for a couple of hours
and that's it that's it yeah I'm like it
like all day I'm doing something like
it's either fraud it's either something
but I was all day all night all day all
night yeah and I and I just I mean I I
changed my outfit like four times a day
my whole look like I changed my hair
twice a week
due to the fact that you know if I go
still for a living in red hair then I'll
change it to blue hair and then they're
looking for that one girl you know I
mean like that's why I do it I try
because I don't want to get I mean I
have I know I have to be realistic and
understand that it could happen one day
but I try to cover my ass like all the
time because I just I can't be
incarcerated because
then that will put me into like not
seeing my kids like even more you know
talking about your hustle which is a
unique one yeah
uh on YouTube is gonna I understand slow
you down I understand but
to be honest like the only people that I
worry for to see this video is my kids
maybe more my 14 year old but I had to
tell her like two weeks ago she was very
upset at me because
she's like you don't love us you don't
love us you don't know what happened to
you and I said
I will I didn't want to tell her what I
was going through you know living in a
tent and doing all these things but that
was the only way for me to make her
understand that it's not that I don't
love her it's just that I am in a you
know
there's a lot of things going on in my
life and they're not like nor like you
know like everyday things to other
people you know it's very hard and then
I had to tell her and I told her like
you know don't don't worry like I'm okay
I'm gonna get out of here but I am
currently living in a Ten Mile and then
I'm doing this for a living and then
I mean more things added to it like my
bad choices and
with my partners you know it's very like
I tend to like
like if they're homeless looking and or
if they don't have a job it's like
they're the love of my life you know
like it's crazy and I have to stop that
too because that also that also affects
my life very much and then um also like
gambling it's very
um something that really affects my life
you go to the Casitas uh yeah and then
everything I mean I carried ice in my
purse like you know it's everyday
everything like like there's like days
where I do side bets on anything you
know like
and then people are looking at me like
I'm like yeah I gamble all the time and
that's something that I have to also try
to quit because all this money that I'm
getting for these forklifts are going in
there like you know I I try to give my
kids as much money as I can but
sometimes like
I just can't help it because I think
that I'm gonna be I'm gonna come up on
the next round you know and it just
doesn't happen sometimes
and that really bothers me because it's
like once I don't have no money then I'm
like okay let's go and do it again you
know and and one of those times I'm
probably gonna you know just get a rest
well I usually I did get arrested and I
I have a ankle monitor right now
yeah and it's kind of embarrassing
because I mean you don't have to look at
me like some guy was like I don't know
what's more sexy of your hair or your
ankle monitor I was like oh my God stop
talking about it and it's kind of like
you know it kind of like it affects my
all day whatever because of my outfits
it kind of looks like ghetto or you know
just people look at me like I'm a bad
girl which I am kind of but not like
that so but I I
I agreed on taking it because I I mean
if not I was going to be incarcerated
until the court or until everything you
know was settled down so I said okay
let's do it but it it's really
uncomfortable and then I don't even
charge my phone so it's like forget to
charge this thing and they get notified
on this so they you know I have text
messages where like your thing is dead
and I'm like damn I can't find a charger
and then you can't even go buy these
chargers at Best Buy or something you
know like they're unique Chargers that
only you have so it's kind of like you
know like if I have to carry everywhere
I go I have to be really careful with it
too because if I lose it that's it
what's your biggest fear right now my
biggest fear is to miss out on my kids
like most important things
my three first kids I've been there I I
know that I did a really good job with
my kids but my last baby she's um
her name is blue rose and I haven't been
there you know ever since she was born
the only baby I didn't breastfeed and
that's the only baby that I didn't sleep
with right so I'm very afraid that that
will um
you know affect her as she was growing
up and I know that my other kids know
that I'm I'm a good mom but she doesn't
but it's funny how I still I FaceTime
her all the time and she's like she's
like she calls me mommy like if I was
there every day which I'm not but I
think that's something that you know
that probably that's like a blessing you
know because I because God knows I'm a
good mother you know but I'm just I'm
fighting my own demons and there's a
bunch of them you know so so I'm gonna
get through it but I'm just I fear that
I'm not gonna be there for the moments
that I have to be there you know and
protect my kids as you know because I'll
protect them or anything you know would
you describe yourself as
self-destructive
um
kind of
the gambling in the yeah yeah lifestyle
you're leading
I mean just to start off with the
with the people that I you know that I
have romantic relationships with like
they're just like real bad like choices
like I'm telling you as like if you
don't have a job if you don't like it to
work if you're lazy and if you want
you're going to pay for everything come
to me you know what I mean like they're
the love of my life and it's crazy
because like I'm very like you know I'm
very ambitious and I like to to have
money that's something that makes me
really like you know it makes no it
doesn't make me happy but I I really go
for that feeling for that smell of the
money I love it you know and and it
doesn't make you happy but it does make
life very very comfortable and
and I just like to give like I well when
I was cashing out on fraud two years ago
I um I gave my kids experiences like
that they were gonna remember all their
life and that's what I like to do with
my money like ice my mom's like save
some money I said no no because my money
makes you evil mom so that's why I spend
it all it's like go go get it again you
know like I don't want to just hold on
to it because then you know it just it
just changes your feelings mom she's
like oh my God then what are we gonna do
tomorrow like oh God would help us out
that's what I always tell her and she's
like no but you can't I'm like but you
know what that's something that helped
me out because as much as I lose the
money like that then I go out there and
get it again you know and that's
something that keeps me motivated at
least you know but yeah it's
that's just probably one of my biggest
fears and then yeah just time I think
what would you say is your greatest
strength
um
I think my green strength is like
I guess just me you know like
I am very like I adapt everywhere I I am
very like I have a charm like I get away
with a lot of things because of the way
I am and the way I look and you know and
it's just and you know what
I'm not telling you that I'm happy or
that I look like I'm fine without my
kids but like this is the only thing I
was left with when all these things
happened my my father was killed in
Mexico right
and um
and I was a daddy's girl so that
devastated me as well so that we're
losing my husband was a sexual whatever
you know he was going through and then
losing my job which I loved I really
enjoy and love this so much
um
I was only left with like the way I look
you know like my looks and the way I
carry myself so sometimes like when
people want to like put me down it's
like come on like that's the only thing
I was left with right now because I
don't have my kids I lost everything I
lost my house I lost everything
so
you know I think that like just me my
charm it has gotten me away like I
gotten away from plenty of stuff with
just being me and just talking to
somebody it just it just makes them like
okay go ahead you know and then like I'm
over here like with illegal stuff on me
and they're just cool it's fine okay
have you seen it before yeah so it's
like you know that that's something that
and I I sometimes like I wish I I
wouldn't like like this or have this
charm because
like
it's just so awkward for everybody looks
at me like I walk down the street and
it's like I just picture myself like
being a little vagina walking because
everybody is just like I can't even go
to the cut and do my makeup because
there you go there's a guy already like
trying to creep up on me and like and
I'm like damn idea come on like is it
that bad like is it
I don't know it just sometimes people
make it seem like like I I don't know
like you know it's just they want to be
there around me or but it's like it's
not even that bad like trust me you guys
are gonna regret it at the end of the
day you know but
um but yeah that's probably one of the
things yeah my charming just I don't
know everybody just likes to read around
me
you like bad boys no not even bad boys I
wish I would I would love a bad boy no
I'm telling you I like I like like
Homeless looking like don't have no jobs
no Ambitions in life you know like
really I guess I mean that's the that's
kind of like yeah if you're like that
come to me I'm telling you like it's
crazy like it gets worse as yours go by
like it just gets worse like what is it
if it attracts you I don't know like
it's crazy like because like as you can
see like I'm very clean I changed my
outfit all the time and it's like and
then I'm dating these like not they're
not like dirty like in a nasty way but
like I'm very like you know I take care
of myself a lot like my shirts staying
I'm Not Really Gonna Change it like I
don't like to you know and then these
guys are just like sweaty and then it's
like oh yeah okay come on you know like
or the shoes are dirty and it's like oh
yeah okay I don't mind that and it's
like I have to just stop that because
that's very like it doesn't go with my
image or you know kind of like people
look at me like what like you're dating
that guy I'm like yeah
but then I see so much good things on
them like you know and they're in their
inner them or whatever
that is crazy but I mean you just have
to kind of like stop because it's kind
of like getting to me already
emotionally what do you go through you
get depressed or angry or actually I'm
not depressed I'm just saying like my
just my days are going darker like
just the fact that I can sleep with my
son again or that I haven't slept with
him like in three years that's something
that bothers me every like not I'm not
gonna tell you every time I go to sleep
because I really don't that's the reason
I think I don't go to sleep because I
think I don't like I don't want to go to
sleep without him you know so I keep you
know like just being up all these hours
and it's like and it's funny because
people are like when you crash you crash
no I crash for like four hours five
hours and then I'm up again because like
is my my conscience is just like come on
get up get up because I feel like I
don't deserve to rest because I guess of
everything that's going on or whatever
I'm putting my kids you know through how
old are you uh I have my 14 year old
daughter I have a 10 year old daughter a
nine-year-old son and then a
two-year-old baby oh baby girl and how
old are you I'm 32 32. and you're
smoking meth yeah
how often do you smoke
all day like
yeah all day yeah and all night yeah but
it's funny because I'm like I'm already
immune to it like at the beginning it
was like I was smoked and it was just
like uh okay come on my partners and I
will be like let's go over to a room for
like nine hours straight right into you
know get like you know have sex and
stuff for like continuous hours but now
it's like I guess as time goes by like
I'm able to eat I'm able to like sleep
if I want to but I really don't want to
like everything like it's just it kind
of like you become immune to this right
and luckily I'm uh like I'm a functional
user or whatever because I have my
brother my brother uh started to use
drugs maybe like two years ago and my
brother's burned out you know but once
he's out of it like that's my brother
again but once he's on mess like or yeah
he's just
he's burned out you know and it makes I
tell him all the time like don't let it
get to your mind you're strong you're
you're better than that look at my dad
my dad used to sell drugs when he was 13
years old and he was a he used drugs all
his life and my daddy was never you
never saw him like burnt out or saying
something already just [__] and my
brother does so it's kind of like I tell
him all the time but you know only he
knows what he's going through so
you know and and I I think my kids are
the ones that keep me from being you
know like just not going insane I guess
or burning out or stuff but
yeah there's it I mean
only if they put Perfection the the
whole dope thing and
you know they could probably make it
legal for some people because it helps
me out it is it's not nice to say
because I really don't want to be you
know doing drugs all my life but
at the time when I started using it it
helped me out a lot because I feel like
if I wasn't doing it I wasn't able to
take care of my kids
Foster my brothers which were they were
like um problem kids I had to go to
school I had to go to I had to get a
like a d-rate thing for my little
brother had to go like to classes
because it was like like it was like a
d-rate I don't know like because they
rate them based on their behavior and
then on top of that I had to manage the
four restaurants I was a manager for the
four of them I had to go to Pomona San
Bernardino Downey hunting apart in West
Covina at the same time in one day you
know so that and then well and then
finding out what happened to my husband
or or like what was going on with him at
that time you know like I really don't
think he was uh he was gay but you know
sometimes you tend to like you know I
guess have like I don't know maybe was
he using math as well yes so I think
that was it but I was trying to make him
explain to me like what did I do like
look at me why are you doing this to me
but maybe he didn't even know at that
time you know so it's very confusing for
both of us and and I love that man so
much you know so it did devastate me
because he was in the father of any of
my kids but he helped me with the
fostering of my brothers and taking care
of my kids yeah but meth seems to do
things to people sexually that yeah no
other drugs yeah because I think they
they because look to me it's kind of
normal because I could be in love with a
woman as much as I could be in love with
them with a man I don't see people by
gender for me everybody see I could be
enough with me like a girl and a guy it
don't matter to me right as long as I
feel attraction to them but like my my
ex-husband was very like Macho like
Mexicano right so
for him to like accept the fact that he
kind of have that little like you know
like it was very hard for him so maybe
he didn't even know how to handle that
but I told him baby it's okay like if
you want to you know you want to try it
out go ahead like you know like I don't
mind I just don't want you to I don't
want to feel like like you're hiding
stuff for me because then I have my kids
involved and you live in our home so I
want to know what you you know what you
like or what you don't like and you know
and I want to be able to decide if I
want you to be part of my kids life or
not and that's something that really
bugged me because my daughter you know I
have a 14 year old daughter I have to
take care of all that and I always did
but not knowing what has really like you
know what what he really liked it was
kind of like it was scaring me at some
point you know and I just didn't want to
like affect my kids or or for something
that happened that I wasn't able to fix
you know because those type of things
you you're not able to fix ever you know
and it would affect my kid or my brother
or anybody in my family for the rest of
their life you know and I wouldn't want
to carry that on my back you know I just
it would be really
really hard for me to like overcome that
because the guilt is something that
really I don't wish it upon nobody you
know like the remorse no that's out like
at I don't even wishing about my worst
enemy I don't because it's really
because when my father died
he left me he got deported and he left
me with the whole thing you know taking
care of my brothers my mother you know
so I remember I I would I would call him
through FaceTime and I would be like he
wouldn't answer something so I would be
like why the [__] did you leave me you
left me with with my mother with my
little brothers like we need you out
here and then I was like but but watch
when when you die you're gonna die like
like by yourself because you left me by
myself so I was very angry at the moment
right I didn't wish this about my father
but
it happened like that my dad was picked
up by some people in Mexico because he
[__] with the wrong people so he was
like you know how the the sikarios
whatever they and and I wasn't able to
go in and figure out what happened
because first of all I wasn't born here
second of all
I'm the oldest of everybody so I had to
take care of the whole family you know
well my at least my little brothers
so that's something that for for it took
me a whole year to realize that it
wasn't because of those messages that
this happened to my father it was
because he [__] with the wrong people
right because he was very like grimy you
know and and he was like he were like he
would put like factories to bankruptcy
like in a matter of like two weeks like
you will have like the the drivers
deliver all the merchandise to our house
right and like he managed to like steal
like like as much as he could he got
people together and people were going to
bankruptcy after they hired him two
weeks after you know so he now I
understand that he [__] with the wrong
people over there so that's why this
happened but imagine my dad my dad
you know like dying the way I wished it
upon him at the moment that he left me
alone it kind of like it was it was hard
for me because I was like maybe because
I said that that's what happened but it
took me a whole year to realize that and
that's something that really affected
that's I think that's something that
really got to me you know me because I
was always around drugs all all my life
and I I would never use them I was
against it like I would know I would
take my kids like on the weekends to
like anywhere they wanted to go you know
and it was like we would drink me and my
husband but that's it we'll just go to
sleep and get up in the morning and I
try that for so long but just I think
that the remorse of like what's she not
about my father when he was like
everything to me
it was just like very hard you know and
and that thing is I think is what really
started this whole me being out here now
and doing what I do and all that what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um what is it
I think
it was just
what's gonna happen is gonna happen
regardless
right like I busted my ass and like
protecting my my family my my kids
trying to make my mother act the way I
wanted her to act but at the end of the
day like I can't control people's
actions or or just simply I can't
control people and I always try to do
that right like I always try that Mom
don't do this mom or I try to protect my
brothers from doing this or or trying to
like you know like talk him out of it
and I can't because what's gonna happen
is gonna happen you know I mean if maybe
if I wouldn't be so stubborn trying to
find out why my husband was doing this
why my father you know all that all the
stuff that I was trying to figure out
and take control of maybe I would have
taken the fact that he had these likes
and then I would have been okay with it
you know what I mean I would have not
gotten off on him because I was they
like two hours hitting him you know but
what finally got me that I I took my
kids out of school I put them in the
donut shop with my oldest brother and
then I beat him up outside of school I
was biting him like the principal had to
call the cops and and my kids weren't
there but there were other kids and and
I wasn't it wasn't it's not nice you
know to just other kids to see somebody
getting so violent so I was I was
ordered to go like to like domestic DV
classes but I was like the Predator I
had to sit with like guys you know that
beat up woman you know and it's like
yeah like like yeah they're like you
ain't no victim so go to the the other
part you know and I was like no but like
but I I was you know and my kid I never
hid my kids but at the end of the day
they were afraid of me because of how
with my partner at the time you know so
well now me and my partner are perfectly
fine we're really good friends now and
and I and I and I told him to forgive me
you know because
I could just Davis and I explained to
him why but I think that just trying to
not control the whole situation like
what's gonna happen is gonna happen
regardless you know what I mean and I
should just let things go you know like
and then yeah that's it yeah
all right Evie thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome wish
you lots of luck yeah well thank you
thank you